[Musik]
Deutschland hat einen neuen
Verteidigungsminister auf
pannenministerin Christine Lamprecht
folgt Boris Pistorius SPD-Urgestein löst
das die Probleme bei der Bundeswehr der
Probleme haben wir ja generell genug von
Corona bis zur explodierenden
Energiekosten viel gibt es zu besprechen
jetzt mit diesen interessanten Gästen er
ist heute mit Personenschutz hier in
Morddrohungen gehören zu seinem Alltag
Islamkritiker hammelt Abdel Zermatt der
auch in seinem neuen Buch vor dem
radikalen Islam warnt gerade jetzt nach
den Silvester Randalen fordert er eine
ehrliche eine offene Debatte und erklärt
wie Europa vom radikalen Islam
unterwandert wird sehr viele Deutsche
sind verunsichert was dieses Jahr wohl
bringen wird da Astrologin Silke Schäfer
schaut für uns heute in die Zukunft
Wirtschaft Krieg Gaspreise was liegt da
alles vor uns das verizius gleich hier
ja weniger Heuchelei und Lügen werden
schon mal ein guter Anfang dass mein
Bild Politik Reporterin Zara riffler
blickt kritisch auf die Aktionen der
klimaextremisten die ihrer Meinung nach
dazu beitragen den Industriestandort
Deutschland zu schwächen und ich freue
mich sehr über Doktor Björn Peters er
ist Physiker er ist Energieexperte und
er befürchtet wenn wir so weitermachen
dann ist der Industriestandort
Deutschland gefährdet er fordert sogar
noch mehr nicht nur den weiter der
Betrieb der Atomkraftwerke nein es muss
noch mehr gebaut werden das gleich Thema
hier bei uns in der Sendung und jetzt
starten wir aber hier bei viertel nach
acht ich freue mich sehr dass sie heute
bei uns sind in unserer Sendung es gibt
einiges zu besprechen beispielsweise
jetzt neue Recherchen aus den USA der
dort hat sich ein Journalist einem
deutschen Thema gewidmet und meint ganz
klar die Politik aber auch bayern-tag
hat Einfluss genommen auf Twitter das
belegt er mit in eine E-Mails die
deutlich machen sollen dass dort Druck
gemacht wurde auf Twitter bestimmte
Veröffentlichungen zu verhindern oder
zumindest zu verstecken das ist eines
unserer Themen hier jetzt bei viertel
nach acht ich freue mich sehr Zara
hältst du das für möglich dass Einfluss
genommen wird wir haben das gesehen in
dieser Krise dass viele Meinungen
kritischer Experten nicht gehört wurden
dass sie auch mundtot gemacht wurden
dass sie diffamiert worden jetzt eine
neue Recherche aus den USA eines
investigativ-journalisten der behauptet
er hat interne E-Mails vorliegen und die
zeigen dass Bayern Tag ganz klar auch
Druck gemacht hat aus Sorge vor Aktionen
überrascht dich so eine Recherche nicht
überrascht das gar nicht mich wundert
das auch gar nicht ich meine mich
überrascht dass er wenn jetzt jemand
sagt oh ähm damit hätte ich nicht
gerechnet wir hatten wirklich mehrere
Jahre der Pandemie wo man das auch nicht
mehr kritisch sehen wollte wo man das
Leben an höchste Priorität gesetzt hat
und auch kritische Stimmen ganz bewusst
negiert hat und nicht mehr zugehört hat
und das zum Beispiel Bayern Tag ein
Unternehmen ist das Geld verdienen will
viel Geld und auch lobbyiert und auch
Druck machen kann das wurde oder
Zeitlang vergessen und wollte man
wahrscheinlich auch vergessen und ich
denke da werden wir noch viel mehr davon
hören also Autos ein bisschen mehr als
Arbeit jetzt betrieben wird ein bisschen
Licht ins Dunkel zu bringen bisschen
Aufarbeitung glaubst du jetzt erst tut
und während der Pandemie nicht getan hat
das ist ja auch interessant die
Journalisten z.B hätten sich ja auch dem
annehmen können während der Pandemie
aber man tut es jetzt eigentlich wo die
Pandemie vorbei ist also zu spät ist
deiner Sicht zu spät aber es muss sein
und jetzt erst recht muss eigentlich
alles aufgearbeitet werden
einige haben es natürlich gemacht der
nicht alle Journalisten haben vor allem
nichts gemacht gleichzeitig kann man
sagen hat Dr Peters ist das nicht
einfach was ich da jetzt gerade
beschrieben habe ist muss einfach
soismus so wie er überall passiert ja
ich denke schon also so viel Geld zu
verdienen ist passiert sowas natürlich
auch follow the money ist immer die die
Maßgabe eigentlich in jedem
Gerichtsprozess und auch in jedem
lobbyismus-prozess also wirklich
überraschen kann das eigentlich nicht
sie hat das nicht überrascht die
Aufarbeitung dennoch auch ein Thema das
jetzt hier in Deutschland immer weiter
hoch kocht viele stellen sich fragen
sich wie geht es weiter steuern wir auch
dann wieder in die gleichen Fehler von
vorher rein tun wir genug in Sachen
Aufarbeitung
ich fand die ganze Zeit sehr schwer muss
ich sagen ich habe einen Freund der ist
Epidemiologe der Stabilität des
Professor der hat mich immer gerade
gerückt dann habe ich wieder von anderen
Leuten ganz andere Sachen gehört aber in
diesem Dschungel zurecht zu kommen war
glaube ich auch für die Profis extrem
schwer
was vielleicht sehr enttäuschend war ist
dass man nicht so in der ganzen Breite
die Experten angehört hat ich würde mir
vorstellen dass ein Helmut Kohl der
hätte sich die drei vier Protagonisten
die jetzt sehr unterschiedliche Meinung
sind zu sich ins Kanzleramt geholt hätte
gesagt hier ist ein Raum hier ist der
Schlüssel den man jetzt zu ihr habt was
zu trinken aber ihr kommt erst wieder
raus wenn ihr euch geeinigt habt auf
eine Haltung und das hat halt nicht
stattgefunden ist war glaube ich eine
recht einseitige Debatte und die führt
natürlich zu Fehlern wenn Sie das erlebt
hat auch ihrer Umgebung gab es da
kritische Stimmen den man nicht zuhören
wollen es gab kritische sogar liberale
Menschen Künstler die auf der Straße
gegangen sind und waren gegen diese
corona-politik sie wurden alles rechts
abgestempelt obwohl sie alle eigentlich
ideologisch links anzusiedeln waren und
das ist genau es kam eigentlich zu einem
Paradigmenwechsel nach Kohl in der Zeit
von Merkel hatte sie die Leute auch nach
sich
im Kanzleramt geholt hat sie aber nicht
gesagt er muss euch einigen und dann mir
sagen sondern er muss dieses Thema so
annehmen wie ich ich sehe und das wird
jetzt fortgeführt am Thema Corona und am
Thema Migration merkt man dass es eine
große Diskrepanz gibt zwischen dem was
tatsächlich passiert und das was in den
Medien berichtet wird da sind wir auch
gleich bei ihrem Thema gleich viel ver
Schäfer sieht möchte ich auch noch
einmal zu diesem Thema aber abholen was
hat das mit ihnen gemacht wir haben ja
auch über das Vertrauen über
Aufarbeitung der corona-krise gesprochen
wie blicken sie auf dieses Thema haben
sie noch vertrauen ich habe sehr viel
Vertrauen weil es geht hier um das
Bewusstsein dass wir wir sagen sozusagen
Erwachen es ist ja von den
Konstellationen so ich beobachte das ja
aus einer anderen Perspektive und habe
sozusagen einen Abstand den ich in
einnehmen kann das was ich wahrnehme was
ich sehe und diese Phase der
Aufarbeitung ist jetzt absolut richtig
und zentral weil in der Zeit wo so viel
versteckt wurde wo wir so viel eben auch
online uns überhaupt erstmal unterhalten
haben man darf nicht vergessen dass wir
durch die corona-phase durch sind in
einer in einer Möglichkeit wo wir
überhaupt erstmal alle online gegangen
sind ganz viele Leute sind plötzlich
online gegangen plötzlich mit ganz viele
Stimmen gehört von Menschen die gutes
gesagt haben Menschen die vielleicht
auch nicht gutes gesagt haben aber diese
Art der Kommunikation das gehört zum
Zeichnen ist das Thema gewesen dieser
wie das heißt Zwillinge können das
besonders gut oder nur Zwillinge am Ende
können das das wäre schlecht erreichen
die Energie ja es war ein Fokus auf
dieser Energie für uns alle also
globalen und das ist der Journalismus da
ins Zentrum gekommen ist mit Lüge und
Wahrheit war so klar für mich mich hat
das vollkommen ruhig gelassen natürlich
auch habe ich viel beobachtet aber das
ist jetzt wo die Themen sich verschieben
da können wir natürlich genau dass das
jetzt angeführt zur Aufarbeitung kommt
das phänomenal absolut richtig und sie
sagten auch sie haben noch vertrauen ich
hoffe das sehen sie auch so quasi mit
ihrem Blick in die Zukunft über den wir
uns auch gleich noch unterhalten wollen
dennoch muss man sagen dass man sehr
sehr viele ernste Themen dabei Folgen
von Lockdown Menschen die unter der
Impfung leiden oder die unter
Ausgrenzungen leiden für wie wichtig
glauben sie ist es für die Menschen dass
das alles jetzt in einer offenen Debatte
aufgearbeitet wird absolut wichtig und
so zentral und wir haben die
Möglichkeiten dazu da die die elektron
Möglichkeiten sind gegeben und jetzt
braucht es die Menschen die mutig sind
es anzupacken und die Wahrheit
aussprechen ist die Politik der mutig
genug packen wir das an der Zeit wir
haben dich nur Politiker wir haben
verlangen schon gar nicht mehr viel wenn
Sie das sagen oder trauen sie es ihnen
nicht zu also schauen Sie die Politik
sollte für die Menschen da sein nicht
andersrum und jetzt nehmen die Menschen
dasselbe in die Hand so dass die
Politiker erfahren werden was es
bedeutet wenn die Menschen Aufstehen das
ist der Trend gut das wird auch der
Trend für dieses Jahr sein vielleicht
sogar die Sterne absolut und noch da
schauen wir gleich und noch darüber
hinaus was heißt darüber hinaus ich
glaube das spricht man nachher drüber
gehen
weil es mich fasziniert aber sie haben
komplett Recht darüber sprechen wir
danach wir sprechen hier viel in dieser
Sendung über vertrauen wir sprechen viel
über Aufarbeitung und wir wollen hier
vor allem eins wir wollen eine offene
Debatte führen und da sind wir er hatte
es aber direkt in Ihrem Thema drin das
haben wir bereits abgesprochen und das
ist genau auch das was sie fordern und
zwar auch mit Blick auf Migration auch
mit Blick auf den Islamismus es ist ihre
Zeit es ist Ihre Kamera wir sind
gespannt auf ihre Thesen
Europa glaubt dass Mittelalter hinter
sich gelassen zu haben keine
Religionskriege mehr kein Gewalt im
Namen keine Gewalt im Namen der Religion
keine Unterdrückung der Frauen und
Minderheiten im Namen der Religion aber
mein ehrt sich das Mittelalter kommt
zurück nach Europa mit der Einwanderung
der Islam erlebt gerade sein eigenes
Mittelalter er weigert sich durch einen
Prozess Aufklärung zu gehen er weigert
sich Frauenrechte anzuerkennen er
weigert sich Religionskritik anzunehmen
und zu akzeptieren und sich damit
auseinanderzusetzen und
das Ergebnis davon sind kaputte
Wirtschaften in der islamischen Welt
eine verheerende Menschenrechtslage vor
allem auch Frauenrechte in der
islamischen Welt
Bürgerkriege und Religionskriege
zwischen Sunniten und Schiiten und all
diese Phänomene wandern jetzt und kommen
nach Europa und beschäftigen Europa und
werden Europa in den nächsten
Jahrzehnten beschäftigen Terrorismus
Jugendgewalt in migrantenviertel
religiöses Mappen Mobbing an Schulen und
Client Kriminalität das ist nur die
Spitze des Eisberges und es wird noch
schlimmer und die Politik bleibt und
tätig und auch die Medien da erkenne ich
auch eine Diskrepanz zwischen dem was
passiert und dem was wirklich berichtet
wird die Politik und die Medien machen
sich teilweise Zukunft Liezen das
Islamismus in Deutschland weil sie nicht
kritisch genug über dieses Thema
sprechen
dazu mehr in meinem aktuellen Buch Islam
eine kritische Geschichte dass ich
morgen in Berlin vorstelle
ZuschauerInnen Zuschauer damit alle
eingeladen wir rennen in die Bude
vielleicht
ein im ernsten Thema bleiben und ich
habe gerade eben als ich sie vorgestellt
habe gesagt sie sind hier mit
Polizeischutz die stehen hier bei uns
vor der Studio Tür erklären Sie uns
einmal wie konnte es dazu dass sie so
leben müssen weil das Mittelalter nach
Europa auch gekommen ist früher weiß
ganz normal dass jeder Mensch Jesus
kritisieren konnte oder die Bibel jetzt
wenn irgendjemanden den Koran oder
Mohammed kritisiert dann lebt er
gefährlich dann lebt er unter Polizei
Schutz Mitten und Europa im 21
Jahrhundert das ist für mich ein Skandal
das ist ein Angriff auf meine Männchen
würde und auf meine würde alles
Schriftsteller dass ich mehr als sieben
Personen Schütze brauche und gepanzerten
Fahrzeug und eine Schuss sicherere Weste
brauche um meine Meinung um einen Buch
über den Islam vorzustellen das ist für
mich ein Skandal aber
die Demokratie lebt immer noch ich weiß
nicht wie lange noch und ich darf nach
wie vor auch in so einer Sendung meine
Thesen vorstellen aber in den meisten
Medien nicht mehr
sie bekommen Morddrohungen mehrfach in
der Woche fast jeden Tag was steht da
drin was wird ihnen da vorgeworfen es
wird mir vorgeworfen es wird mir
vorgeworfen dass ich vom Westen bezahlt
werde um den Islam schlecht zu reden um
den Propheten zu diskreditieren es wird
mir vorgeworfen dass ich ein Ungläubiger
bin ich gehöre geköpft ich gehöre
getötet
und eigentlich der Westen bezahlt
mittlerweile die Islam verbinde die hier
Salon für gemacht werden die Anhänger
von Erdogan werden von der Politik und
von den politischen Stiftungen hofiert
nicht ich im ich werde langsam aus dem
Diskurs verbannt weil ich den Islam
kritisiere ein elementares Menschenrecht
Religionskritik wie wäre die Aufklärung
ohne Religionskritik das ist eigentlich
und vor allem in ihrem Buch tun Sie
nicht nur das also sie Lob den Islam für
so viele Facetten sie blicken auch noch
mal historisch zurück auf die
Blütezeiten des Islams sie sagen auch
der Politik ganz klar Musliminnen und
Muslime können wir in Deutschland so
nicht behandeln also ich muss sie da
einmal selber in Schutz nehmen sie haben
genau das was sie auch fordern eine
offene Debatte nicht nur Argumente in
die eine Richtung lassen sie uns da
einmal den Finger in die Wunde legen was
läuft schief erstens richtig also es
gibt viele Muslime die in diesem Land
leben die sind friedlicher Menschen und
sie sind auch loyalisch Staatsbürger
aber es gibt auch Anhänger des
politischen Islam die das Mittelalter
aus den islamische Länder importieren
all diese Phänomene die für für
Bürgerkriege dort sorgen werden hierher
gebracht und mit Steuergeldern
eigentlich finanziert auch an deutschen
Schulen die jungen Muslime an deutschen
Schulen lernen wie Erdogan zu denken wie
Islamisten zu denken sie lernen in
westlichen Schulen wie sie den Westen
hassen können das ist
mehr als Grundgesetz die meisten
Muslime die hier leben achten das
Grundgesetz aber es gibt eine große
Minderheit die sagt nein zuerst kommt
der Koran zuerst kommt die Sharia ihre
Loyalität gilt nicht dem Gemeinwesen
oder dem Rechtsstaat sondern der
muslimischen Oma der muslimischen
Gemeinschaft dem Imam dem Clanchef und
das ist natürlich gefährlich und das ist
deshalb dass die Phänomene die wir sehen
wie Jugend Gewalt das ist nicht nur ein
soziales Problem weil sie arm sind oder
weil sie arbeitslos sind sondern weil
sie auch von zu Hause aus gegen den
deutschen Staat und gegen diese
Gesellschaft angestachelt werden und
gehetzt werden sie betrachten ihre
deutschen Nachbarn alles Ungläubige weil
sie Schweinefleisch essen oder Alkohol
trinken oder Sex vor der er haben und
wie können Sie mit diesen Menschen als
Staatsbürger umgehen wie können Sie
diese sich mit diesen Menschen
anfreunden wenn Sie glauben Gott hat sie
und ich muss auch sie hassen so kann man
sich nicht integrieren und so lebt die
Frustration weiter und so kommt dieser
Gewalt die langsam gährt
wir wollen hier eine offene Debatte
führen gerade in diesem Zusammenhang das
erwähnen sie auch in ihr in ihrem Buch
ist ein ganz schnell bei Kritik die Rede
von Rassismus deswegen kann man annehmen
sind viele vorsichtig geworden zu
formulieren Finger in die Wunde zu Ihnen
in die Debatte hineinzugehen wie nimmst
du das war so da gibt es zwei Aspekte
oder bzw kommt von zwei verschiedenen
Strömungen die eine Strömung ist dass
wir eine große Gruppe haben am
legalistischen Islamisten die zwar auch
eine Minderheit sind aber eine große die
schon anzugucken Krawatte tragen die in
der Wissenschaft sind in den
Universitäten und ich kann die Namen
rechtliche nicht sagen weil sonst würden
wir verklagt werden so ist es äh
Islamisten benutzen das am Arsch Mittel
um Kritiker wie ihn und mich
einzuschüchtern das habe ich jahrelang
erlebt und diese wissen diese Islamisten
Anzug und Krawatte schreiben dann Bücher
über Hamid abdissermatt stellen Ihnen
als islamophob da als rassistisch und
versuchen damit natürlich jede Kritik an
politischen Islam und dann
islamistischen Strukturen zu
delegitimieren und die zweite Strömung
ist von wem das auch ausgeht sind von
links grünen Politikern in Deutschland
am stärksten aber auch teilweise von ich
kann es auch von konservativen
Politikern z.B in Nordrhein-Westfalen
und jedenfalls diese Politiker haben
sich irgendwie indirekt auf die Seite
geschlagen von Islamisten weil sie in
ihrem Weltbild einfach das nicht sehen
wollen das Parallelgesellschaften gibt
dass es Islamisten Anzügen gibt und was
ich beobachten kann als Journalistin die
sich jahrelang mit Islamismus befasst
ist definitiv das legalistischer
Islamismus wächst und zwar enorm seit
den 50er Jahren in Deutschland wachsen
islamistische Strukturen die sind nicht
kleiner geworden sondern sind größer
geworden und vor allem die die tolerant
geben die jetzt Gendern dieses gender
Sternchen benutzen die werden größer und
die Lobby ihren die Politik aber diese
parallel Entschuldigung diese
Parallelgesellschaften wo sind die in
der Hauptstadt in Berlin oder an anderen
Orten also
wir haben diese Parallelgesellschaften
überall in in Deutschland das ist nicht
nur Neukölln und Kreuzberg sondern auch
in anderen Stadtvierteln in Berlin ich
sehe das also ich werde fast in jedem
Stadtviertel angegriffen auf der Straße
auch wenn ich mit der Polizei laufe ich
kann mittlerweile in Beirut oder in
Dubai ohne Polizeischutz laufen aber
nicht in Berlin das ist unmöglich so
schlimm ist das Problem schon geworden
und diese Politiker die sind nicht naiv
sie wissen ganz genau was passiert sie
lesen auch meine Bücher und sagen toll
tolle Thesen ich glaube das auch aber
sie sind opportunistisch erstens
sie haben wirtschaftliche Interessen mit
der Türkei und mit den Golfstaaten und
sie wollen sie nicht verärgern sie haben
auch Interessen mit
Islamverbänden in Deutschland weil sie
die Wähler mobilisieren CDU oder SPD
oder die Grünen zu wählen und man will
diese Wähler nicht verscheuchen und dann
manche haben Angst alles rassistisch
oder islamophob abgestempelt zu werden
und so kann man nicht ein Problem lösen
wenn man das Problem nicht einmal nennen
darf und wenn Menschen die das Problem
nennen sofort alles rechts ich bin alles
andere als recht ich bin eigentlich mit
dem Gedanken von Jean Paul Satire
sozialisiert und intellektuell erwachsen
geworden aber sie zwingen mich immer an
den rechten Rand nur weil ich die den
Finger in die Wunde lege und sage wir
haben ein ernsthaftes Problem mit dem
Islam und mit der Migration und über
dieses Problem zu reden ist heißt nicht
Generalverdacht müssen alle Muslime im
Gegenteil ich finde
Islamkritik heute zu Tage ist nicht nur
ein Menschenrecht sondern ein Menschen
Pflicht den der Islam hat ein Problem
und es liegt im Interesse der Muslime
selbst dass sie über dieses Probleme
reden
auch jetzt in der Silvesternacht ja als
wir diese Randale haben und die haben
versucht eine Debatte hier in
Deutschland zu führen die wir aber nicht
hinbekommen haben zu führen stattdessen
haben wir darüber geredet was wie wir
die Debatte nicht führen sollen und was
rassistisch ist und vor allem kam das
wieder von links grünen Politikern die
dann auch hier gefordert haben die die
Debatte über die Herkunft zu beenden wir
brauchen eine Debatte die Ideologie frei
ist natürlich ohne Verurteilung und
Rassismus zu führen und das das Proteste
ist doch das links grüne Politiker ja
Menschen die herkommen hier
haftpflichten aus anderen Ländern vor
allem die Nahen Osten den Schutz bieten
wollen aber genau diese Menschen die
Leiden sind doch die Leidtragenden davon
denn die werden ja auch hier
traumatisiert wenn in Deutschland wieder
rufen darf dann dann ist das ein
Retraumatisierung und das und dann
nehmen die Politiker die Menschen eben
nicht in Schutz und man darf nicht
vergessen wie rassistisch der politische
Islam ist
Herr Peters nehmen Sie das auch so wahr
haben sie Sorge vor einer Drohnen
Radikalisierung also ich frage mich vor
allem wann der Islam eigentlich falsch
abgebogen ist und ich ich muss eine
kleine Geschichte zu erzählen ich mich
meine Diplomarbeit tatsächlich natürlich
meine Eltern gewidmet als Sponsoren aber
dann alkovarismi das war der derjenige
der die das Rechnen mit der 0 erfunden
hat und und popularisiert hat vielleicht
hat das aus Indien mitgebracht was weiß
man nicht aber er war eine also ein
leuchtende Größe im 9 jahrhundert ähm 19
Jahrhundert und er ähm das war eine Zeit
wo der Islam unglaublich produktiv war
wenn
hat gesagt die ähm und das war weit
fortschrittlichen Verhältnis zum zum
Christentum man hat gesagt
allah ist Gott also aller ist
allumfassend also ist auch das Studium
der Natur ist ein Studium Allahs also
muss das gottgefällig sein und dagegen
hat man bei uns irgendwelche
platonischen Ideen hochgehalten hat
gesagt die Naturforschung
wollen wir hier eigentlich nicht so
richtig und paar Jahre nach nine eleven
habe ich mich dann sehr stark mit mit
dem Koran und so auseinandergesetzt und
habe gemerkt dass es ein für eine
unglaubliche ein Fortschritt war in der
Antike im siebten Jahrhundert es ist
eine sehr tolerante Religion eigentlich
also ganz anders als man es heute kennt
aber was wir in Europa halt hatten ist
das noch nicht mal die aufklären die
Aufklärung eher das Ende dieser
geistigen Entwicklung die begann mit den
journastikern die
Institutionen geschaffen haben also dass
das nicht der König war sondern das
Königtum und diese Entwicklung hatte
Islam
offensichtlich nicht mitgemacht jeder
Dorf Imam darf eine Fahrt war
aussprechen ohne ohne ohne
Funktionen oder ohne ohne Kontrolle und
was ich sie eigentlich gerne fragen
würde ist wo ist da eigentlich der Islam
oder wann ist der falsch abgebogen warum
hat er sich nicht weiterentwickelt warum
reden über solche Themen heute überhaupt
ja hast du zuerst man macht immer den
Fehler zu glauben dass der Islam an sich
für diese Entwicklung im Mittelalter
verantwortlich war für die Mathematik
und die Philosophie es war nicht der
Islam sondern die griechische
Philosophie die ins Arabische übersetzt
wurde sie hat eine Wissensrevolution in
Gange gesetzt es gab ein paar tolerante
Herrscher die eigentlich viele von ihnen
waren sogar homosexuell die damals ja
der regiert haben und sie waren tolerant
und und auch die Vermischung von Völkern
die Juden haben eine Rolle gespielt die
Christen die Perser alphavisma war kein
Araber sondern ein Perser und so waren
die meisten Wissenschaftler und die
meisten Philosophen zu diesem Zeitpunkt
wäre der Islam für diese Entwicklung
verantwortlich gewesen dann hätte diese
Entwicklung in Mekka und Medina ähm
beginnen können nicht in Bagdad und
nicht in Cordoba wo ehemalige
Hochkulturen dafür verantwortlich waren
wann ist der ist die islamische Welt
abgebrochen alles die islamik cancel
culture
entstanden ist als die religiösen
Gelehrten gesagt haben Philosophie ist
haram ist nicht es verboten alles sie
bestimmt haben du darfst den Koran nicht
kritisieren früher dürfen wir das schon
das war schon ab dem 12 Jahrhundert und
da
geschah im 12 Jahrhundert in der
islamischen Welt was heute in Europa
passiert mit ganze culture und mit
Identitätspolitik und mit Tribalismus 7
Mentalität die Rationalität war weg und
langsam kam Emotion kamen Emotionen und
kamen religiöse Identitäten und die
Religion bestimmte was geschieht und was
gesagt gesagt werden wird heute ist es
wieder Identität und Religion die
bestimmen was wir sagen und was wir
nicht sagen soll und Europa muss
aufpassen und das ist das womit ich
gemeint habe dass das Mittelalter
langsam nach Europa einwandert einmal
noch lösungsorientierte denken geben Sie
uns ein paar Hinweise darauf dass die
Politik was wir als Gesellschaft was
Jahren werden muss um dieser
Radikalisierung die sie in ihrem Buch
beschreiben Einheit zu gebieten was
passieren muss damit das friedliche
Zusammenleben von dem wir alle Träume
möglich ist wir müssen mit Muslimen
umgehen erstmal alles Individuen alles
Bürgen und nicht alles eine Gruppe und
nicht als Kinder das sagen sie auch sehr
handelt wird als wie Kinder wenn ich
jetzt Islamkritik unterbinde aus
Rücksicht auf religiöse Gefühle dann
behandle ich Muslime wie Kinder nicht
wie erwachsene Menschen die kritikfähig
sind die auch auf Kritik mit Kritik
antworten können das ist das erste
zweitens die Politik muss aufhören diese
Islamverbände salon-projekt zu machen
mit Fördergeldern zu unterstützen sie
werden sowieso von der Türkei und von
den Golfstaaten gelenkt um hier
türkische und arabische Politik auf
deutschem Boden so machen das muss
beendet werden die Bildung muss sich
befreien von diesen Islam Unterricht und
programmbildung die von den
Islamverbänden
kontrolliert werden und endlich mal muss
die Politik und die Medien und die
Zivilgesellschaft für die Freiheit
einstehen
es tut mir manchmal leid dass ich
Menschen die in der Freiheit geboren
sind über die Freiheit unterrichten muss
das will ich gar nicht
ihr musst mich unterrichten über die
Freiheit ihr seid da geboren ich bin in
der Unfreiheit geboren in Ägypten musste
mich von mal von der politischen
Diktatur und von der religiösen Diktatur
befreien um hierher zu kommen um meiner
Meinung frei zu sagen und am Ende muss
ich dann unter Polizei Schutz stehen um
diese Meinung zu sagen das muss beendet
werden da mussten die Politiker die
Schulden uns die Antwort was ist schief
gelaufen sie müssen die Lösungen
präsentieren und Sie müssen das Kind
beim Namen nennen kein Mensch kann ein
Problem lösen ohne zuerst das Problem
Clip und klar zu benennen
eine offene Debatte eine offene Debatte
bei diesem Thema eine offene Debatte die
wünscht auch du dir Zara wir sind schon
direkt beim nächsten Thema drinnen auch
du fürchtest eine Radikalisierung du
hast auf jeden Fall die Nase voll von
Heuchelei und von Lügen deine Meinung
deine Zeit ich finde es reicht es muss
jetzt aufgehört werden dass
klimaaktivisten verharmlos werden als
Klimaschützer und als klimaaktivisten
denn was wir jetzt in lützerath gesehen
haben finde ich ist mehr als nur radikal
und da haben sich eben auch Aktivisten
gemein gemacht mit diesen Extremisten
die unsere Polizei also unsere
Gesetzeshüter angegriffen haben als
Faschisten beleidigt haben sie haben
beträgt auf sie geworfen mit Stein mit
Molotov Cocktails ein Polizist vor Ort
meinte zu mir sie haben mit alles auf
die Polizisten geworfen was sie gefunden
haben überhaupt auf dem Boden und
trotzdem verharmlosen Politiker und
Medien seit Jahren und immer noch und
auch während masterrad als als die
Räumung lief diese klimaaktivisten und
wir haben das gesehen beispielsweise im
WDR dort durfte 50 Minuten lang eine
Pressekonferenz von den lützerath
Besitzern gezeigt werden total
unkommentiert und eine Sanitäterin die
in Wahrheit Aktivistin ist und Mitglied
bei der Grünen Jugend die durfte dann
von Polizeigewalt reden obwohl sie gar
keine Beweise dazu vorlegt und bis heute
auch nicht vorliegt und und eigentlich
fragt man sich doch ob das alles eine
klimaschow war denn diese Heuchelei ist
doch gewaltig die wir dort erlebt haben
ein eine Geisterstadt die sich
eigentlich zu dieser Protest in einer
Geisterstadt der sich eigentlich
entwickelt hat zu einer reinen selbst
Inszenierung wenn die grüne Aktivistin
Luisa Neubauer plötzlich Fotos und
Videos von ihm macht wie sie ein Buch
liest wenn sie wenn sie davon getragen
wird von den Polizisten mit einem Schild
mehr selbst Inszenierung geht nicht und
wie heucheln ist das eigentlich von den
Grünen politischen Beobachter innen aus
dem Bundestag die dort eigentlich das
Geschehen beobachten wofür sie selbst
abgestimmt haben und ich frage mich
wirklich wie groß kann die Heuchelei von
grünen Aktivisten und Grünen Politikern
noch werden
da war ganz schön was drin
ich möchte sie zunächst mal fangen Sie
Verständnis dafür für junge Menschen die
fürs Klima kämpfen die sich dran ziehen
die eigentlich sagen ihr alten ihr müsst
unsere Zukunft verändern nicht nur
Verständnis sondern sogar Bewunderung
das ist sehr gut wenn junge Menschen das
tun aber was nicht gut ist wenn sie
selbst gerecht sind wenn sie glauben
alleine im Besitz der absoluten Wahrheit
zu sein wenn sie ihre Gegner oder
irgendeine Kritiker mundtot machen und
das passiert sehr oft ist wächst eine
Wolke Generation die sehr intolerant ist
gegen andere Meinungen und das ist
genauso gefährlich wie Klimawandel Frau
Schäfer was befürchten sie steuern
wieder in seiner Spaltung der
Gesellschaft rein brauchen wir ein
bisschen mehr Pragmatismus auch in
dieser Debatte ich wollte gerade noch
anschließen also ich meine schon auch
noch widersprechen dass wir nicht sagen
können die ganze Generation wächst jetzt
auf in eine Richtung wie sieht das eben
beschrieben haben sondern das ist jetzt
ein Aspekt und dieser Aspekt wird
natürlich sehr gepusht durch die Medien
das ist vollkommen klar das ist ja auch
die Aufgabe der Medien aber mehr
Pragmatismus ganz wichtig über alles
gesehen wenn ich von außen schaue ist
Bildung immer wieder Bildungs hatten sie
vorhin auch sehr schön angesprochen das
ist wichtig ist oder auch wie sie jetzt
von historischen kommen dass wir die
Zusammenhänge lernen zu verstehen dass
wir mit der Bildung und das ist
phänomenal möglich heute mit den neuen
Medien ja das sehr viel natürlich wollen
nicht alle zu Hause ein Bildschirm
lernen aber wir haben ganz neue
Möglichkeiten überhaupt Informationen
erhalten zu können uns Gedanken machen
zu können austauschen zu können das ist
jetzt ein Anfang wir sind jetzt in einer
unglaublichen markanten total wichtigen
Schwelle wo es kippt vom
sagen wir so vom niederschwelligen oder
niederträchtigen ja hin zu einem
bewussteren von einer bewussteren
Gesellschaft wir sind in diesem Übergang
Übergänge sind immer eben sehr radikal
das was am Sterben ist das alte bewusst
und das ist mir sehr laut ja aber da
muss ich direkt Einlenken weil sie
meinten das ist die Aufgabe von Medien
die habe ich Aufgabe von Medien ist aber
kritisch darüber zu berichten und ich
finde ganz viele Medien tun das nicht
und vor allem leider in letzter Zeit
immer wieder der Rundfunk war das auch
bei Anne Will gesehen eine Talkshow bei
der ARD wie die Position besetzt sind
das ist dann mehrheitlich von grünen
Position besetzt ja eine grüne
Politikerin zwei grüne Aktivisten vor
allem Luisa Neubauer und kriter tunberg
also da hätte man auch eine eine davon
hätte gereicht und Luisa Neubauer darf
dann halt da auch sitzen und viele sagen
was dann einfach so stehen lassen wird
und das ist total unkritisch und das ist
nicht die Aufgabe von den
öffentlich-rechtlichen wenn ich total
sitzen Frau tunberg und von Neubauer
nicht aber was würden sie den beiden
Frauen entgegnen würden Sie hier mit
unseren Tisch sitzen also wenn man das
Klimaproblem so hoch aufhängt wie die
das tun und da gibt es gute Gründe was
zu tun oder auch nicht zu tun dass eine
ganze Parade de Werte aber wenn man das
tut dann sollte man eigentlich top-down
sich überlegen was sind eigentlich die
wirksamsten Maßnahmen und da finde ich
das so abstrus dass eine letzte
Generation
sich
festklebt mitten im Winter im Beton weil
sie ein Tempolimit und einen neuen
euro-ticket fördern das ist ungefähr so
viel von der ganzen von dem ganzen
großen Kuchen den ich lösen müssen und
als wenn man top down sich das überlegt
dann müssen schauen wie groß wie wie
kriegt man auf der Welt die CO2 Emission
runter die kriegen sie in Deutschland
runter und dann gleichzeitig aber das
ist ja gerade grüne Politik
Atomkraftwerke abzuschalten ich glaube
ich darf danach noch mal was dazu sagen
also wenn sie sich in im im Keller
festkleben würden anstatt an lützi dann
dann würde ich das verstehen aber so ist
es halt irgendwo das verpufft das
verpufft ins Leere ich bin im übrigen
auch da muss ich auch wieder sprechen in
ihrem Sinne fahrschäfer weil ich also
ich habe zwei Töchter in dem Alter die
sozusagen in der wir so Fridays for
future Alter und die haben halt auch
erzählt also das war immer nur eine
kleine Minderheit die sich davon hat
anstecken lassen und es war auch in der
letzten Bundestagswahl so dass die
stärkste
Partei bei den erst Wählern war die FDP
die eben in sehr sehr positives
Zukunftsbild hat und kein
angstgeleitetes Zukunftsbild und das
macht mir dann auch ein bisschen
Hoffnung das heißt sie würden würde
Greta Thunberg beispielsweise jetzt hier
mit einem Tisch sitzen sagen habe keine
Angst vor der Zukunft absolut das ist
nicht so dramatisch
also nein die CO2 ist in der Tat ein
wichtiges Thema und das über das muss
man reden aber und wir werden das auch
lösen aber es geht über Technologie und
nicht über Verzicht weil sie können dem
Unternehmer dem Kleinunternehmer in
Bengalen in Vietnam in Ruanda dem können
sie nicht sagen du musst jetzt aber
verzichten sondern der will ja auch zu
uns aufschließen also müssen wir uns
konzentriert und überlegen wie kommen
wir eigentlich dahin dass alle auf dem
Wohlstand kommen aber dass die
planetaren Grenzen trotzdem gewahrt
werden und dafür gibt es drei Ansätze
das eine ist Konzentration also wir
verbrauchen zu viel Landfläche also
müssen uns konzentrieren und nur
Technologien entwickeln die Flächen
konzentriert sind dann brauchen wir eine
eine bessere Kreislaufwirtschaft weil
wir zu viel Müll in die in die Welt
eintragen das ist eigentlich fast noch
größere Problem als der als der
Klimawandel würde ich mal sagen und das
dritte ist wir müssen das mit höchstem
Bewusstsein machen weil wir ansonsten
eben die das wir können es vielleicht im
reichen Deutschland bisschen was
erreichen aber so viel aber die ganze
Welt wird uns nicht folgen und warum
machen wir das weil wir Nahrung
Rohstoffe und Energie aus der Natur
brauchen und diese drei Dinge das können
Sie jetzt überlegen also sozusagen drei
mal drei Matrix Energie
gibt's dafür Technologien mit denen wir
das erreichen kann entweder den Laboren
oder vielleicht sind die schon fertig
entwickelt die also preisgünstig sind
Flächen konzentriert und eine
Kreislaufwirtschaft ermöglichen und
natürlich gibt's solche Technologien ich
schreibe gerade einen Artikel drüber das
Ding ich kann leider kein so schönes
Buch präsentieren aber ich noch dran
aber ich habe nun mal noch einen anderen
Job das ist ein bisschen schwierig aber
es gibt solche Technologien und deswegen
ist es keine Utopie sowas zu erreichen
sondern das wird in diesem nächsten
Jahrzehnten auch passieren
da kommen solche Botschaften an und auch
du sagst Lüge und Heuchelei darauf
möchte ich noch mal zurückkommen das
sind die Punkte die du ganz konkret
vorwirfst viele Jugendliche denken sich
vielleicht ist doch toll wir setzen uns
für die Zukunft ein Lüge und Heuchelei
an welchen Punkten erkennst du die naja
die Lüge ist ja das man jetzt sagt an
lützerath würde jetzt alles das Klima
genesen also das ist ja ich weiß ja
nicht also da sind die Wissenschaftler
sich uneins inwieweit letzte Rad
wirklich dieses 1,5 Grad Ziel erreichen
könnte wie man sich daran nähert viele
Wissenschaftler sagen ja jetzt schon man
kann das erstmal auch gar nicht
erreichen dieses Ziel was man sich
gesetzt hat also das ist ja schon mal so
eine Art Lügen gestrichen und natürlich
ist es auch Heuchelei was die grünen
Politiker und da betreiben zuerst
stimmen die im Bundestag ab von den
braunen Kohleausstieg und damit Sitze
hat also dieser dealheit das ist dafür
bezahlt das drauf geopfert wird und man
früher aussteigt dafür die stimmt dafür
ab und dann setzen Sie sich
wahrscheinlich ins Auto
und fahren dahin beobachten das und
schreiben noch die auf Twitter dass sie
sich davon entfremden von dieser
lützeraträumung und man müsste das doch
jetzt stoppen noch also das ist total
die Heuchelei ist mein erster für
abstimmt und ganz ehrlich die Grünen
sind sowieso die größte räucherlöschere
Politik von der ganzen Ampel weil wenn
sie wirklich Klimaschutz wollen dann
hätten sie ja wieder die AKWs auch ja
zurückholen können quasi also dass wir
aus den Ausstieg der Peter ist gleich
zustimmen da können wir aber gleich ja
2016 haben die Grünen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen die die Verlängerung
der braunkohle-nutzung damit begründet
dass wir den Atomausstieg haben also die
Grünen waren eigentlich immer eine
kohlepartei und das vergisst man
manchmal und das ist ganz genau unser
großes Thema hier bei 8:15 Uhr nach
einer ganz kurzen Pause bleiben Sie
gerne bei uns bis gleich
[Musik]
sind wir wieder zurück bei viertel nach
acht und es ist keine gute Nachricht
heute deutschland verliert an
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit rutscht weltweit
auf Platz 18 das jetzt eine neue
Untersuchung und da sind wir auch schon
mittendrin in unserem nächsten Thema
denn das mag natürlich auch mit an den
hohen Energiekosten liegen und wir haben
bereits dieses Thema so ein bisschen
hier auch schon berührt in dieser Runde
es geht um unsere Energie es geht um
unsere Energie Sicherheit und dr Björn
Peters ist hier und er sagt so kann es
nicht weitergehen so schafft Deutschland
quasi sich selbst ab es ist ihre Zeit
ihre Kamera
ja die aktuelle Energiekrise ist zu 100%
ausgemacht denn heute Rentner ihre
Stromrechnung nicht bezahlen können wenn
Betriebe vor dem ausstehen denn hat es
vor allem einen Grund das ist eine eine
Fehlentscheidung in der Vergangenheit
das ist der Atomausstieg
die
Kernkraftwerke die wir haben zählen zu
den besten der Welt und trotzdem könnten
sie trotzdem haben wir hunderte
Milliarden in wetterabhängige
Energieformen investiert die nur
funktionieren wenn russisches Gas den
Backup dafür macht in den in den
dunkelflauten jetzt fehlt dieses
russische Gas und die Energieversorgung
ist teurer und unzuverlässiger als
jemals zuvor wenn jetzt auch noch die
letzten drei Kernkraftwerke wegfallen
wird Energie noch knapper und damit noch
teurer und ob das die deutsche
Wirtschaft überlebt das ist hier die
große Frage das werden wir sehen
eine Laufzeitverlängerung von 5 bis 6
Kernkraftwerken hätte
eine sehr stark mildernde Wirkung auf
die Energiekrise wir würden ein Zehntel
der CO2-Emission einsparen wir könnten
ungefähr den Strompreis um ein Drittel
absenken wer die Rechnung nicht glaubt
ich habe sie veröffentlicht in einem
Fachjournal und andere Ökonomen haben
das auch im Wesentlichen bestätigt
und unsere kernkraftwerke sind noch so
gut technisch dass sie noch
jahrzehntelang preisgünstig zuverlässig
und sicher Strom erzeugen können und
emissionsfrei vor allem
Brennstoff könnte für den nächsten
Winter leicht beschafft werden das
dauert dann halbes Jahr dann steht der
auf dem Hof die Menschen die Mitarbeiter
die sind jetzt noch da oder können aus
der Frührente zurückgeholt werden also
was fehlt ist eine einfache Mehrheit im
Bundestag und weil die Grünen sich in
diese Frage so unbelehrbar Verhalten
kommt es auf die FDP und die beiden
großen Volksparteien an und im Übrigen
hätten die auch eine große Mehrheit der
deutschen Bevölkerung hinter sich
deswegen mein Appell an die
Bundestagsabgeordneten handeln Sie
verantwortlich für die Menschen für die
Wirtschaft und vor allem für die Umwelt
geben Sie den deutschen die ist wirklich
verdient haben das Beste was Sie
bekommen können nämlich unsere deutschen
Kernkraftwerke auf Dauer zurück
jetzt könnte man auch argumentieren und
das tun einige wir schaffen das auch mit
alternativen Energien wir schaffen das
wenn wir auf Wind und auf Sonne setzen
habe gerade jetzt gerade das zweite
lng-tannel an den Start gebracht die
Preise sinken sogar wieder der Winter
ist mild alle spielt uns in die Karten
ist doch alles nicht so schlimm ja aber
genau das ist es ja also habe ich halt
vor allem Braunkohlekraftwerke
Steinkohlekraftwerke und Gaskraftwerke
hochgefahren alles nur um diese Klippe
nicht nehmen zu müssen
atomlaufzeit Verlängerung aber immerhin
Unabhängigkeit vom russischen Gas das
ist wunderbar aber schauen Sie mal auch
zu welchen Kosten und es ist einfach
empirisch kann man das sehen überall auf
der Welt wo man versucht vom CO2 in der
Energieversorgung runterzukommen gibt's
Ende zwei eigentlich zwei Typen von
Ländern die einen machen das mit
Wasserkraft und Kernkraft und die haben
sehr niedrige Energiekosten und die
anderen machen das mit wetterabhängigen
Kraftwerken und mit ganz viel weg gehabt
das und das heißt man muss zwei
Energieversorgungssysteme aufbauen und
dann wird es eben auch doppelt so teuer
und der Faktor 2 stimmt sogar auch
ungefähr
Zara du darfst Reinecke ich sehe schon
dass du auf heißen in dem Zusammenhang
auch noch sehr gut quasi sitzt greift
gerne eine die Diskussion ja also wir
leben gerade in einer Zeit
aufgrund der Energiekrise wegen des
Ukraine Kriegs wo weltweit sich etwas
ändert in Sachen Atomenergie wo wir
wirklich eine Trendwende weltweit
erleben international Japan ist aus
eigentlich aus der Atomkraft
ausgestiegen jetzt steigen sie wieder
ein Italien Niederlande Belgien
Frankreich Polen wahrscheinlich noch was
vergessen die konzentrieren sich jetzt
alle auf die Atomkraft und das ist ein
ganz wichtige Energiequelle jetzt für
die und Deutschland macht mal wieder den
German Alleingang ich habe auch das
Gefühl es ist so eine Kombination aus
Partei Ideologie der Grünen und diese
German Angst sich der Atomkraft
hinzuwenden und ich finde es wirklich
nur noch absurd dass die Grünen alles
dafür geben würden um einfach nicht
irgendein Atomkraftwerk anzuschalten und
wir haben auch eine ganz andere
Situation in Deutschland
mit den Atomkraftwerken die viel
sicherer sind als zum Beispiel eine
Frankreich die runtergewirtschaftet sind
und trotzdem tauchen immer wieder solche
falschen Argumente auch auf hatte es
sein als sie leben auch im Libanon ist
das richtig wie blickt man derzeit
gerade auf Deutschland ist das
eigentlich noch der große Big Player in
irgendeiner Art und Weise oder wundert
man sich auch ein bisschen wie die
Deutschen einige Themen angehen ja im
Leben und eigentlich also gibt es eine
riesen Energiekrise es gibt Strom nur
zwei Stunden am Tag und trotzdem
man redet dort nicht so heftig über die
Energie und Energiekrise wie in
Deutschland das ist tatsächlich so hat
etwas mit German Angst zu tun ich habe
auch früher in Japan gelebt und da kamen
dann diese Atomkatastrophe in Fukushima
in Deutschland hat man sofort den Atom
auch Ausstieg entschieden
quasi ohne Parlament und in Japan hat
man nur darüber Debatten geführt wie
können wir Atomkraftwerke
selber machen in der Zukunft und das ist
entscheidend Fortschritt und Angst
können nicht zusammen gehen man braucht
für den Fortschritt tatsächlich
Zuversicht und Rationalität und nicht
dass man die Themen emotional behandelt
wie das Thema
klimawandelt glauben sie wir sind bei
vielen Themen zu emotional absolut wo
zeigt sich das bei welchen Themen sind
wir Deutschen ist die Politik vielleicht
auch sind wir alle zu emotional du musst
mehr Ruhe Pragmatik Fächern das mit der
Ruhe ist ja ganz was zentrales wir sind
überall dort sehr emotional wo wir
abgetrennt sind von großen Ganzen ich
sag das jetzt ganz einfach so wo wir
abgetrennt sind von von den Bewusstsein
dass wir eine Menschheit sind dass wir
einen Planet sind das auf diesem einen
Planeten noch andere Zusammenhänge sind
zu anderen Planeten dass wir uns
abgetrennt haben von der Natur und da
gibt es eben natürlich auch die
Gegenbewegung die sind aber nicht so
laut ja diejenigen die ganz klar jetzt
ich meine jetzt nicht die Klimakrise
sondern ganz viele Menschen die sich
wirklich mit Spiritualität beschäftigen
das sind ganz gewaltiger Trend ich
bekomme ich bin ja mittendrin ich
bekomme das sehr stark mit und diese
Emotionalität das braucht Führung es
braucht ein Bewusstsein sich eben aus
einer Ruhe heraus zu bewegen man kann
sehr gut und sehr klar diskutieren da
sind wir dabei Respekt ja man kann wie
auch hier super Runde Meinungen sagen
und miteinander dann auch ins ins
Gespräch kommen aber wenn wir emotional
ins Gespräch gehen dann gehen wir von
der Frequenz her in einen niederen
Bereich und der macht nie Spaß gemacht
sehr viel kaputt und schlussendlich auch
krank oder auch tot deswegen es ist
jetzt in diesen Übergang in dem wir sind
zu lernen auch durch die vielen
Emotionen die da sind nicht nur in uns
Menschen oder in einzelnen Berufsgruppen
sondern weltweit dass wir lernen mit dem
was uns ausmacht was uns wirklich
ausmacht nämlich der Blick zum Universum
der Blick zur Ganzheit als Menschheit
als Ganzheit dass wenn ich einzelne
Segmente sagen dass jetzt der Staat für
sich und der Staat für sich sondern die
gesellschaftliche schau die wir immer
wichtiger also das auch alle
zusammengehören das ähnelt auch ihrem
Appell dr Peters eben gerade als sie
gesagt haben die FDP die Volksparteien
die müssen jetzt mal versuchen
zusammenzuhalten und alle gemeinsam die
Grünen mit ins Boot zu holen und so ihre
Meinung die AKWs zu verlängern
vielleicht sogar auch neue zu bauen was
glauben Sie wie viel Erfolg wird das
haben glauben sie dass ihr Traum wenn
ich das jetzt mal so formulieren darf
Wirklichkeit wird also ich bin ziemlich
im Austausch mit einigen
Bundestagsabgeordneten ähm ich das die
Frage beschäftigt mit sich natürlich
auch sehr ich glaube dass die die FDP
höchstens ein Führungsproblem hat also
eigentlich außer Christian Lindner sind
eigentlich alle wirklich sehr stark
ausgeprägt für eine Laufzeitverlängerung
sie wissen auch sie brauchen nicht
wirklich beim Wähler anzutreten wenn sie
das nicht hinkriegen und wenn sie die
Wirtschaft runterfahren deswegen das ist
also
das ist die die Selbstverständnis einer
Wirtschaftspartei das darf die nicht
machen
bei der CDU die tastet sich sehr mutlos
an das Thema ran weil sie eben noch eine
klimaunion im Nacken hat das sind
eigentlich grüne die wo man nicht ganz
versteht warum die in der CDU sind ich
habe es noch nicht verstanden aber der
das behinderte Diskussion im Inneren
deswegen schreiben diese mutlose
Anträge im Bundestag ja wir wollen für
zwei Jahre die die Kernkraftwerke noch
erhalten die Energiekrise wird noch 10
Jahre dauern solange werden wir die
Kernkraftwerke wirklich brauchen
mindestens und bei der SPD gibt es ein
bisschen ein paar Leute im eher
gewerkschaftsans Bereich die natürlich
auch wissen ihre industriearbeite
verlieren ihre Arbeitsplätze und damit
sind die wahrscheinlich auch als Wähler
weg wenn die nicht in die pushen kommen
und jetzt wirklich was machen und
deswegen also da ist ein ein bisschen
Rest Hoffnung habe ich aber jetzt nicht
da letztlich ist es irrelevant weil die
ganze Welt Kollegen
riffler hat gesagt die ganze Welt baut
Atomkraftwerke wir werden jetzt auch ein
Jahrzehnt der Innovation sehen im
Bereich der Kernkraft
es wird eine globale Renaissance der
Kernkraft geben zu es wird eine
verhundertfachung der Anzahl der
Kernreaktoren geben weltweit und ob
Deutschland ein bisschen gleich dabei
ist oder erst in 20 Jahren wenn die
Wirtschaft mehr oder weniger schon
runtergefahren ist früher oder später
kommen die früher oder später da kann er
spät für einige zu spät sein also lassen
Sie uns auch einmal das Szenario
besprechen was passiert wenn wir auf den
Zug nicht aufspringen was glauben Sie
was passiert dann gut wir werden jetzt
das sehr teure LG dann weiterhin
brauchen sehr häufig wenn die
Kernkraftwerke fehlen werden die auch in
der in der in der Mary oder wenn sie
sehr oft Preis setzen sein für den
Strommarkt die Stromkosten werden sich
permanent auf 150 € rund plus minus dann
50 jeweils einpendeln früher waren die
zwischen 30 und 50 ist also eine
Vervielfachung und eine ganze Reihe von
30 bis 30 bis 50 Euro pro Megawattstunde
an der an der Strombörse also drei bis
fünf Sense pro Kilowattstunden
Produktionskosten jetzt sind wir bei
eher so bei 15 Cents und das bedeutet
für ganz viele Unternehmen die
energieintensiv produzieren die
im internationalen Wettbewerb stehen
dass die ganz ganz großen Standort
Nachteil haben und es findet ihr heute
schon statt bASF hat gesagt sie werden
es werden in den USA nach China gehen
weiter große Firmen die wir hier
brauchen die abwandern ganz genau und
wie viele Jahre kann das gut gehen bis
ich in Deutschland für uns alle
Arbeitsplätze Wirtschaft bis das
wirklich spürbar wird das Problem ist
also erstens es wird jetzt schon spürbar
die Lieferketten sind gestört das hat
viel mit Corona zu tun aber es hat auch
tatsächlich viel mit dem also
Düngemittel fehlen Ammoniak fehlt das
sind alles eben sehr energieintensive
Produkte die oder mit Erdgas hergestellt
werden das ist nicht witzig also das
kann auch sehr schnell zu einem
Zusammenbruch führen wenn wenn ein paar
Firmen das reicht ja mit 5% der
wichtigsten firmenausfallen dass dann
die anderen keine Produkte mehr haben
mit denen sie produzieren können und das
ist die das das was es so gefährlich
macht jetzt mit der Energiepolitik so
rumzuspielen und so fahrlässig solche
Entscheidungen zu treffen dass man die
Kernkraft nicht weiter anfasst und und
auslaufen lassen möchte das also ihre
Appell aber auch eine sehr bittere
Prognose wenn wir da in die Zukunft
schauen deswegen ist es jetzt wirklich
Zeit dass wir noch einmal in die Zukunft
schauen und ein bisschen Optimismus hier
in unserer Sendung verbreiten Silke
Schäfer das ist ihre Aufgabe jetzt
sozusagen das verloren hier bei uns zu
Gast viele Menschen machen sich Sorgen
derzeit wie geht das nächste Jahr für
uns weiter mit der Wirtschaft mit den
Frieden mit der Welt für einen
persönlich würden uns sehr freuen wenn
Sie uns einen kleinen Ausblick geben das
Jahr 2023 ist es Ihre Zeit ja das 2023
geht sehr rasant und zwar ziemlich genau
so rasant wie wir mit unserem Planeten
Erde durch den orbitsausen nämlich mit
hunderttausend Stundenkilometer fliegen
wir genau jetzt durch den Orbit das darf
man sich gerne mal wieder
dagegenwärtigen das Jahr 2023 hat eine
sehr spannende Dynamik wenn ich jetzt
von oben schaue ich bringe jetzt mal den
Blick von oben ich habe gehört es war
noch nie eine Astrologin in diese
Sendung also ich darf gerne jetzt den
Blick erweitern in die Konstellation von
denen wir sprechen nicht das geht nicht
nur politische Konstellation sondern
auch astrologische Konstellation und wir
haben ein ganz ganz markanten shift der
erkennt was in den Frequenzen und diese
shift kommt nur alle ungefähr 250 Jahre
einmal vor das heißt wir haben hier eine
Energie wir nennen das die Wassermann
Frequenz die sehr viel stärker wird und
zwar für den nächsten 20 Jahre das hat
ganz viel zu tun mit Energien mit
Frequenzen die entdeckt werden was aber
man hat mit Manifestation des Geistes zu
tun mit den vielen Menschen die anfangen
sich auch zu organisieren es ist eine
Kraft von benennen ist power to the
people was wir eben schon bei der
Politik besprochen hatten es ist nicht
mehr so dass die Menschen sich alles
sagen lassen werden wir hatten vor 500
Jahren das war genau das Jahr 543 diese
Konstellation ebenfalls und das war der
Moment wo Kopernikus seine Thesen
veröffentlichte das nicht die der Planet
Erde im Zentrum ist sondern dass die
Sonne im Zentrum es mussten sie
vorstellen der hat den Papst ein
vollkommen neues Weltbild offeriert und
dass ich dann auch durchgesetzt hat und
genau und so eine Schwelle sind wir
jetzt auch unsere Weltbilder ändern sich
radikal und das hat mit der totalen
absoluten ganz klaren Digitalisierung zu
tun alles was digitalisiert werden kann
wird digitalisiert und das können wir
gleich näher vertiefen wir haben wenn
wir sie nach diesem Jahr Fragen doch
ganz viele andere Zyklen und eins ist
der wichtigste Monat ist der März und
der April wo
wir hinschauen dürften weil das so Chaos
Monate sind da kommt unglaublich viel
powers zusammen sehr viel Wut sehr viel
Ärger könnte im Feld sein das heißt auch
hier für alle bitte atmen in der Ruhe
bleiben und wir haben dann anschließend
das wird sehr sehr spannend und sehr
dynamisch eine Phase wo wir diese neue
Zeit die sogenannte die vernetzende Zeit
das erste Mal so richtig spüren und das
ist auch für Sie natürlich ganz wichtig
in Richtung wie gehen wir oder überhaupt
energetisch weiter das sind die Monate
ab Ende März dann der April der Mai und
der juni 2023 wir werden alle
geschäftlich privat politisch
gesellschaftlich eine erste Idee
bekommen was es heißt wenn wir uns
richtig vernetzen das hat eine
Schattenseite und eine Lichtseite die
Lichtseite sind die wunderbaren
Möglichkeiten sich neu zu informieren
und vollkommen neue Innovation das ist
das große Thema aus dem Boden zu
stampfen die sind nämlich alle schon da
die haben sich alle schon vorbereitet
die Schattenseite da weiß ich immer
daraufhin auf das Christopher Projekt
beispielsweise wir sind heute in der
Lage in so ein
Mikroorganismen uns zu bewegen dass man
die DNA ausschneiden kann und die
genschere scheint mir ist natürlich mit
dem Nobelpreis belegt worden aber mir
scheint das die genschere etwas ist was
uns absolut total wirklich bewusst sein
muss wir sind heute imstande Menschen zu
klonen und da stelle ich hier die Frage
es gibt noch viele andere Themen aber
ich stelle hier die Frage ist der Mensch
ein Auslaufmodell weil das wichtigste
was jetzt immer wichtiger wird und dass
wir dann ein Zentrum an Zeitraum für den
nächsten 20 Jahre ist dass wir mit der
Ethik dass wir die Ethik ins Feld
bringen und der Digital Ethiker digital
ethikerin wird absolut der Beruf der
Zukunft
jetzt gerade zugehört alle haben genickt
als wüssten sie auch alle bescheid
wir haben hier am Tisch Physiker
Journalisten Autoren glauben sie an die
Sterne glauben sie an die Energien
glauben Sie dass es das gibt was uns
zusammenhält
Konstellationen in den fernweiten die
wir hier vielleicht gar nicht so richtig
interpretieren können ich finde das sehr
sympathisch was sie vorgetragen haben
aber ich bin ein sehr hoch rationaler
Mensch bin und ich glaube dass
ich jetzt hier einfach öffentlich auch
aber ich glaube dass unsere Zukunft
davon abhängt wie wir uns entscheiden
wie wir handeln wie wir denken alles
Menschen ich glaube nicht dass unser
Zukunft oder unser Schicksal in den
Sternen
liegt aber ich glaube auch dass wir in
rasanten Zeiten leben man muss nicht ein
Prophet sein um das zu sehen und ich
glaube auch dass die Menschen jetzt zu
wachen gerüttelt werden
die stehen auf und sagen ich will auch
beteiligt werden ich lasse mich nicht zu
einem Marionette machen der Politik oder
der Medien oder der Weltwirtschaft oder
was auch immer ich will mitmachen wir
leben in Zeiten in einer Zeitenwende und
es wird sich sehr viel verändern ich
befürchte aber dass unsere Politiker
nicht auf der Höhe dieser zeitenwände
sind sie sind
das wichtige das Volk steht auf und das
ist dieses andere dat und das ist 1789
wisst ihr alle noch oder wissen Sie alle
noch das war der Moment wo aus der
Monarchie in Frankreich eine Republik
wurde weil die Menschen aufgestanden
sind wir sind genau in dieser Zeit die
Menschen werden wach und ich denke da
machen sie machen wir alle sehr viel
Arbeit im in der Öffentlichkeit zu sagen
hey denkt nach fangt an lasst euch nicht
alles von top-down hatte ich vorhin
gehört top down sagen weil die
Strukturen top-down die werden sich
ausschlafen und es wird die Power und
die Information kommt von unten die das
Volk wird anfangen wieder
wieder zu sagen wo es lang geht und dann
noch ein sehr wichtiger Punkt ist
natürlich dass die Art und Weise wie wir
mit dem technologischen Fortschritt
umgehen immer ist immer immer ist was
religiöses dabei zum Beispiel oh äh
jetzt kommt Gentechnik dann der Mensch
ist skeptisch und denkt das wird uns
zerstören das wird dann Jurassic Park
wieder jetzt hier wieder hergestellt äh
oder
künstliche Intelligenz auch da da da der
Mensch ist jetzt ein Auslaufmodell nein
der Mensch ist ein wunderbares Wesen und
hat das im Laufe der Geschichte bewiesen
der ist auch ein furchtbares Wesen und
hat so viele Kriege und viel viel Leid
auch aber er hat auch seine Geschichte
gelernt und ist nie richtig wirklich
zurückgegangen sondern der Vorschritt
geht immer nach vorne vor 200 Jahren war
die skalaverei eine ganz normale Sache
heute jeder Mensch auf der Erde fast
jeder Mensch echte die Sklaverei und
akzeptiert so was nicht Frauenrechte
darüber sind wir uns alle einige das
mussten wir nicht noch mal verhandeln
Kinderarbeit all diese Phänomene der
Mensch hat aus seiner Geschichte gelernt
aber mit Zuversicht und migrationalität
hat er die Welt verändert nicht mit
Emotionen und die Füße
Aberglaube oder Irrationalität
zum Thema Astrologie auch ein bisschen
noch tiefer gegangen in das was das
nächste Jahr für uns alle bringen könnte
auch eine Herausforderungen an
Menschlichkeit an das wie sich viele
Menschen vielleicht auch innerlich
verändern wollen was glaubst Du ist
Astrologie überhaupt dein Ding oder
sagst du dir philosophische Diskussion
gerne Sterne keine Ahnung aber leider
eine absolute Realistin das heißt ich
kann damit nicht viel anfangen aber es
ist toll dass das gibt definitiv ich bin
da ein bisschen pessimistischer deswegen
auch was unsere Zukunft betrifft und
muss da wieder dran anknüpfen was Sie
gesagt haben am Anfang der Sendung wo
sie meinten dass wir das Deutschland
wieder oder der Westen der ganze Westen
wieder in einen Art Mitte Alter verfällt
und das gab mal ähm eigentlich der erste
die Epochen eingeteilt hat und da
drunter Renaissance und dann kommt
wieder der verfallen und ich glaube wir
leben so ein Zeitalter das Verfalls und
unsere Politik wird auch nicht da
rauskommen über was wir gerade geredet
haben dieses ideologische und diese Burg
Politik die die Realitäten nicht
anerkennt vor allem mit Islamismus dass
wir Integrationsprobleme haben dass wir
ideologisch an die Energiepolitik
rangeht ich glaube daraus kommen wir
nicht heraus ich glaube eher dass es
auch sich verschlimmern kann und ja das
ist meine pessimistische Sichtweise auf
das ja ehrlich gesagt Sie haben ja zum
Glück noch die optimistische wir haben
ja am Tisch quasi alles vertreten ich
möchte einmal von Ihnen wissen wer sind
denn jetzt in jeder schaut natürlich
auch auf seinen Horoskop viele wollen
sie an der Runde nicht wissen ich bin
Stier lass ich mal so kurz fallen können
wir gleich noch mal nach der Sendung
dieser hier 23 schon aber wer sind denn
jetzt vielleicht die großen Gewinner die
großen absahne was sind die Menschen die
sagen können 2023 das wird mein Jahr
darf ich da schon in Ihrem Unternehmen
sich freuen können die ist
selbstverständlich ganz oben auch
natürlich
weil wollte nichts anderes hören ganz
wichtig ich meine ich habe jetzt einen
Einsatz hier mal reingeworfen ja wir
besprechen so viele unglaublich viele
Aspekte mit natürlich Betrachtungsweise
und ein ganz wichtiger und sehr schöner
ist die Zunahme der spirituellen der
spirituellen Bewusstseins der Menschen
wir sehen das an den vielen vielen
Meditationen weltweit die sind natürlich
jetzt auch durch die
Online-Möglichkeiten geht das ganz
anders es geht alles um Frequenzen wir
werden ganz stark
frequenzmedizin entwickeln Frequenz
Heilungen über Frequenzen uns
miteinander austauschen wir werden mit
anderen Frequenzen von anderen Planeten
sprechen werden Energiefelder übrigens
für die nächsten also ich habe den
ganzen spannendes Aspekt schwanden
Aspekt bis 2034 ganz neue Ressourcen mit
atomgesteuerten Raketenantrieb
beispielsweise das sind alles so Themen
die 34 optimistisch aber wir haben
solche
die Ränder sind selbstverständlich ja
sie jetzt im Moment gerade mit dem
Glücksplanet im Zeichen Stier ab Mitte
Mai
aber manifestiere das Gute Stier hat mit
Schönheit zu tun mit Bewusstsein mit
auch mit auch finanziellen Ressourcen
auch denen es vielleicht finanziell
gerade nicht so gut geht da haben wir
alle jetzt Möglichkeiten und das ist
spannend wie es als anfängt zu
interagieren wir sind ja derart vernetzt
und vielleicht wäre es sinnvoll wenn sie
sich mal mit der universellen
Verschränkung auseinandersetzen ist
faszinierend wie alles miteinander
Energieebene verbunden ist wir ziehen
sozusagen da einen Ecke vom Universum in
den alles mit ja also ein Mensch das hat
die Philosophie wir mal attacker damals
auch gleich gesagt ein Mensch wenn sich
ein Mensch bewegt bewegt sich das Ganze
Universität dr peter ist für Sie als
Physiker sie sitzen nebeneinander ich
sehe sie aber dicken und sie
beschafft beschäftigen sich ja mit den
Zahlen sie von auch vom Bürger und jetzt
hören Sie Energien und all dies und mit
was man sich beschäftigt
wenn sie innerlich den Kopf oder haben
sie da für eine ja ein Herz ein Sinn als
Mann der Wissenschaft weiß ich natürlich
dass alle großen Astronomen ihr Geld
hauptsächlich mit Astrologie verbient
haben das kann ich nicht ganz negieren
also auch der genannte Kopernikus die U3
und wie sie alle heißen das war damals
so also vielleicht ist er da was
dahinter es ist außerdem so dass das
naturwissenschaftliche Weltbild ist ein
geschlossenes es beantwortet die oder es
ist erstmal es ist dafür da neue Fragen
zu stellen aber wenn neue Fragen
gestellt werden dann entwickelt man
Methoden um innerhalb eines
geschlossenen Systems diese Fragen zu
beantworten und ähm die Verschränkung
von Elementarteilchen ist zum Beispiel
jetzt also mittlerweile eine Banalität
gab auch eine Nobelpreis für den für den
Zeilinger aber was ist jetzt wirklich
bewegt auf auf
universeller Ebene das kann könnte ihn
kein Physiker ehrlich sagen wenn er
redlich ist
also das sind einfach Erkenntnisgrenzen
wo die Physik an Grenzen stößt aber als
Mensch und auch ein bisschen als Christ
und
[Musik]
finde ich das sehr unterstützenswert
weil sie sagen ich beobachte das nämlich
auch dass im Moment sehr vieles im Fluss
sind dass auch dass man viel mehr ins
Gespräch kommt als noch vom halben Jahr
mit Menschen aus dem ganz anderen
politischen Lager weil die alle irgendwo
die Nase voll haben von diese
langweiligen intellektuell an öden denn
Debatte in der eigenen Blase das ist
diese Selbstverstärkung das ist doch
nicht interessant und da ist sehr viel
Offenheit da und ähm es ist sehr viel
auch Wille da zum Kern zu gehen und
wieder wieder auf den also die die
Fragen wirklich zu lösen und was soll
jetzt da sehen also diese Nachwirkungen
die Grünen sind heute zu sein die
Spießer von damals als ich klein war was
die CDU aber heute ist es wichtig die
die die geistig stehen gebliebenen die
dann in lützerath irgendwie so winzig
kleine Forderungen stellen die völlig
daneben sind und also einen echten
Problem wirklich völlig Vorbeigehen tut
mir leid für die aber ich finde das
nicht besonders interessant man muss
dann auch nicht mit denen irgendwie in
einer Talkshow drüber reden unbedingt
und da sehe ich eben halt tatsächlich
Chance auch also im chinesischen ist es
glaube ich das Chance und Krise ist so
das gleiche Schriftzeichen irgendwie
sowas und das das ist halt auch eine
Wahrheit also in solchen Zeiten wo alles
zur Disposition steht werden die Leute
sich müssen sind werden gezwungen wieder
Verantwortung für sich selber zu
übernehmen und das ist im übrigen unser
Motto auch von welchem
Arbeitgeberverband ich trage die
Verantwortung für mein Leben Punkt und
das ist sehr sympathisches Ludwig er hat
aus der aus der denke ähm und das ist
eben die Chance die in diesem Jahr auch
da steht die diese Krisenzeit die
selbstverschuldet ist deswegen betone
ich das auch immer so diese Energiekrise
ist zu 100% hausgemacht da gibt es
keinen sehr russische Einmarsch hat es
verstärkt aber nicht nicht bewirkt und
das muss man wer das verstanden hat
macht sich selbst Gedanken enable sich
selbst also ermächtigt sich selbst
Entscheidungen zu treffen und das macht
mir dann doch ein bisschen Hoffnung ja
und ich muss also wirklich noch ergänzen
also es ist das eine ich bin
verantwortlich für mich selbst das ist
absolutes total zentrale und das hat uns
die mikrop-krise auch gelernt und das
andere ist aber auch das Kollektiv ja
dass wir im Kollektiv auch in den
Gruppen wirklich wichtig auf
Verantwortung übernehmen sollten
füreinander und das ist nicht das man
gegen etwas schießt wie jetzt diskutiert
haben heute mehrheitlich sondern dass
man miteinander sich organisiert und das
Wichtige ist wir sind dann an der stelle
ich betone ist noch mal von einem
vollkommen neuen Weltbild was ich öffnen
wird sind das alles Geburtswehen in den
wir stecken wir sind wir haben einfach
den Joker gezogen dass wir jetzt hier
inkarniert sind und dieses diese Themen
in die Welt bringen dass wir mit den
ganzen Netzwerken die entstehen und den
vielen Parallelgesellschaften übrigens
Kreislaufwirtschaft ist ein ganz
wichtiges Stichwort ganz viele Menschen
die sind nicht laut die hört man gar
nicht sind im organisieren sich selber
unabhängig zu machen von dem was die
Politiker sagen und nur so ganz am Rande
noch von wegen Thema wir haben einen
ganz wichtigen shift jetzt dieses Jahr
im Sommer das ist der Juli 2023 da geht
ein neues Thema los für die nächsten
anderthalb Jahre und das ist die Widder
Energie und widder sind die Pioniere
bitte ist die Energie für uns alle gilt
das sind diejenigen die gefordert sind
vorauszugehen sie und sie machen das ja
alle schon aber das in der Allgemeinheit
Menschen anfangen sich so zu
organisieren miteinander in diesem
Netzwerken wo wir null Ahnung haben wo
wir nachher landen in der Physik nennt
sich das tatsächlich Selbstorganisation
von Systemen hin zu komplexeren Systemen
und das das einzige was man dafür
braucht ist billige Energie und da ist
haben wir mit energiepolitischen kleines
Problemchen aber wir kriegen das hin
okay
einfach kein Problem
das Thema Zeit haben nur ganz ganz kurz
das Thema Energie ist natürlich das Mega
Thema und Energie kommt natürlich von
innen ist klar aber wir werden so viele
neue Energiequellen entwickeln und
entdecken die wir noch gar nicht kennen
also ich bin absolut total überzeugt wir
werden in der nächsten drei vier Jahren
und in acht und die Jahre 2025 26 27
stehen wir komplett waren das mit all
diesen Erfindungen die jetzt da sind die
aus dem Boden stampfen Seins nur mal
leuchtende Bäume ja mit mit ganz viel
Möglichkeiten Energie anders zu
generieren insbesondere sich auch die
große Sonne also das Finden riesen Thema
wir sind an einer vollkommen neuen
umdenke und ich bin total
entspannt und beruhigt auch mit Blick
auf dieses Jahr aber es ist sehr an
ich bin verhalten optimistisch ich
glaube dass der Mensch zu Freiheit und
zum Fortschritt verdammt ist das muss er
aber damit da weiterhin die sind
Fortschritt gestalten kann muss er
rational bleiben und sich vom
deterministischen denken Ablösen von
diesen religiösen Schema Gut und Böse
Sünder und Hölle und
Wahrheit und absolut falsch und man muss
sich von diesem Schema befreien und man
muss auch den Konflikt wagen und
sich sich stellen wir können nicht alles
irgendwie harmonisch betrachten die
Demokratie ist nicht harmonisch das
Leben ist nicht harmonisch die Natur ist
nicht so harmonisch wie wir denken alles
Gerd und steht ineinander Zukunft liegt
wir müssen diesen konfliktwagen und uns
diesen Konflikt stellen und miteinander
offen und klar reden damit wir
weiterkommen können
eine Aspekt ist der kriegerische oder
anderes der friedliche das sind diese
zwei großen Kraftströme auf diesen und
alles geht nur miteinander und ich
glaube darauf haben wir uns an diesem
Tisch hier heute Abend auch geeinigt
dass wir das alle zusammen schön dass
Sie alle hier waren hier liegt noch ihr
Buch hatten sie es gerne in die Kamera
morgen glaube ich dürfen alle zuschauen
und Zuschauer zur Party kommen glaube
ich schon so gesagt ich bedanke mich
ganz herzlich bei meinen Gästen ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei Ihnen
fürs zuschauen morgen sehen wir uns
wieder bei Villach 8 bis dann
[Musik]